my name is rich lesser I'm the chairman
of BCG in North and South America and
the question that I wanted to address is
what keeps me motivated and the answer
is really simple we have the opportunity
to work with companies and governments
and in social impact organizations on
their most difficult challenges and to
really work with them in a collaborative
way to find new ways to work new ways to
have make a difference in to create
value and and work together to really
drive the change and I get to do that
with an incredibly set of talented
people both in the clients that we work
and within dcg in the people that are
here and and that combination of taking
on really difficult problems and being
able to drive impact and working with
amazing people is just enormously
motivating and though it's an intense
job that's what makes me wake up in the
morning happy happy to dive in again